so excited to have drew house in here
you know very well known figure amongst
kind of our team out here and for those
who are maybe watching this video later
a founder of Dropbox how many how many
billions of people do have news yeah no
it's more like hundreds of millions only
309-347-1728 or becoming and how did you
try to set that up so my path started I
was really little so my parents had a PC
Junior so very first computer and I was
really little and my dad so first I
would just play computer games on it but
a couple years later by my dad got it
showed me how there's this thing on the
computer called basic and so I was lucky
they showed me how to write so my first
lines of code and I was like really
really little like how little I was five
that's good yeah yeah I think I saw
those two get in line and so as you can
imagine and it you know turns out when
you're in your when you're little like
that you have a lot of free time on your
hands and so I was always like playing
on the computer and I really loved
playing games and so that was actually
why I wanted to learn programming to
learn how to make games how these things
worked and and like I'm going to insert
of my exploration about the computer
work that would figure out like how
there's like just you know
there's like files and like okay then
when I save a game like I can go into
that file might give myself like 32,767
lives you know like it's so like it
would be all these little things like
that and if only I could access this
file from home and kindergarten I'm
moving this floppy drive around yeah so
I thought I was going to computer games
that was those what I that would does
what I was interested in beginning I was
then as far as a job I start out
babysitting really so I was very good at
like like watching I was like 12
may 11 and like how the parents would
leave I put the kids to bed and I like I
was very good at watching like HBO and
like this is like a requirement I
got only like babysit for like families
that had like good TV and like Pringles
and things like that and I'm gonna do
that as a red flag you're know your
focal point was her cable exactly yeah
and then like trying to like and then
sometimes I'd be like watching something
probably like shouldn't be watching
there'd be like you know shooting or
like bad words and you know I was very
good at like listening from when the
lock went there the key when in the lot
oh yes anyway this has nothing to do
with starring company but sometimes but
then I got a little bit of an upgrade on
the job front I was beta testing a game
and an online game was maybe 14 and they
were taking forever to build the game
and so I started getting restless and
curious and started poking around under
the hood of this game and and I found
all these security holes mmm I found all
these vulnerabilities anyway first you
discover these things you're like oh my
god oh my god you know you
I started impersonating like the
developers and things like that and sort
of making a little like a little bit of
trouble but then I'm like Gaea send them
an email and my guys you really should
fix this you should fix this and you
should have done this this way you
shoulda done this way and I'm like you
know really getting into it and they're
like well do you want to work here yeah
and so I end up working remotely as an
engineer or like they're like do you
want to fix those bugs and I'm like okay
and then you know
is the first kind of startup adventure
first experience of many where my stock
options were worth nothing and this is
14 14 14 years and that so is part-time
remote and but it was like a cool thing
to talk about in like biology class and
and you know like I had to get my dad to
sign all the employment paperwork and
things like that so but that was the
path this is literally working on a game
but then fortunately there you know as
you learn there's a lot of other things
in life beyond like Unreal Tournament
which are really interesting beyond what
Unreal Tournament or Starcraft
tournament yes and so does a little
later on like PC PC eras like more like
this Sierra games like yes quest for
something that you guys work for me it
was for me it was pong okay yeah that
was our timeline that work we're losing
it a little bit we have a little overlap
me and then and then and then you go to
MIT we had you know I met many of us
have been there as well and you know I
watched your commencement speech I
watched your commencement speech which
was great you know it helped that the
guy before you really set a new low in
terms of commencement speech quality but
your speech was really I thought a
really powerful speech and I think it
kind of hit this issue of like you know
you didn't plan on being you know drew
Houston Dropbox founder but you did
think you were going to be an
entrepreneur I mean it seems like while
you were in college you were constantly
thinking about starting a business of
some kind yes and your speech was great
- I mean you I was like going for the no
know what it feels good though you know
you're sort of like there's no
instruction manual for these things I'm
like what am i split you start like
googling excessively for like every
commencement speech ever given before
anyway so but no I I did plan to be I
always was excited about doing something
that was my own thing whether I was
making a computer game and eventually as
I learned more about business and
starting a company I was always I just
turned out that I had joined startups as
an engineer or like an intern when I was
little and then just
didn't never really laugh did you keep
doing that while you were in college I
mean you already had that kind of
experience yeah starting stuff like even
your freshman year sophomore year were
you doing stuff so the the game company
unfortunately folded pretty quickly but
that that then gives me that experience
and let me get a job at a local company
there's another startup actually but it
was kind of an MIT MIT founders so
there's kind of relation there but yeah
in the summers I take classes and then
every summer I would go work at first
couple years it was the company that I
worked at in high school so they were
like maybe you know half hour away half
hour outside of Boston yeah and the one
thing that I think is mysterious for
everyone and even sometimes when people
ask me I don't have a clear answer
because it's it's still a little bit
mysterious is you know how do you
stumble on this thing
that you know just kind of takes off
like wildfire that just just and you
have an interest or I mean you actually
started kind of a little bit closer to
kind of what we do here at KY your first
startup which I think you started your
junior year was was was was around SAT
was called accolade right so my you
never know where these things are going
to go because I mean I think anybody who
grows up programming or whether it's
programming or something else like
there's always tinkering with things
there's always just one project after
another and four and then the first time
I want to start a company I took I had
was I took my junior year off from MIT
so I took it I took a year leave which
end up being was a really great
experience and I promised my parents I
would come back and I did but but so the
SAT at the time was changed there was
like all this all this change happening
right there merging in the writing
section it's gone from 1600 points out
of 24 to from from 1600 to 2400 now I
know there's all kinds of other stuff
happening but this was back in the day
where you know to study for the SAT
you'd have to show up at some like
horrible classroom and like 8:00 in the
morning on a Saturday to listen to some
like seventeen-year-old who didn't want
to be there either
and all those just reading out of a book
like this was the state of the art in
like SAT prep and we're like guys like
the Internet it's not the Internet's
been here for like a little while it's
like it's been here for a long time like
why are we still
was like how my parents study for the
SAT and so and so I teamed up with
actually one of my former teachers from
my high school and we started building a
new kind of course or an online course
for that for the what was then the new
SAT and what's your less I mean what
caused you to I guess not
do that at some point you worked out for
some time you do it was interesting as a
so I started working on cuz I'm like
here's here's like an opportunity here's
something that my co-founder and I knew
really well I mean I just you know I did
I don't know I've I treated the SAT like
one of things I really like to do is
like reverse engineer like how things
work take things apart so whether that's
you know more typical stuff like the
kind of tinkering that kids do or like
you know one of my so I like or the
finding all the security problems in
that in that in that game I when I start
working on the SAT II like I also had to
study for it I was I was like how does
this thing work
and so you can as you know they're
always like little tricks and little
patterns you can take advantage of and I
I'm like okay the only really hard thing
about the verbal section is is the vocab
because like you can in general you can
teach someone how to do a sentence
completion without even really teaching
him it's taught words that are that are
hard so I when I was 16 I wrote all this
software to do kind of flashcards and
adapt and remember which ones I was
getting right and which ones I was
getting wrong and things like that
because I didn't why it was too lazy to
like cut out all the paper flashcards
and like this is so stupid
and so I'd done that and that code
actually was kind of on the shelf for
five years and then and then I when the
SAT changed and I had a friend of mine
who was a teacher who had his own SAT
course and then we had this whole shtick
going I was at MIT he had graduated from
Harvard like you know through as a
result of all this like reverse
engineering the SAT and studying a lot
for I got a 1600 so I was like we had
all like that boxes checked for the
parents and we're like we know how this
works so that it was really just seeing
an opportunity and being like you know
you don't attach too much of an outcome
around it like I didn't have a goal like
I need to make this much money or
whatever sort of like another
interesting project and
probably the best party that was really
just having an excuse to learn about
business in like a rigorous way so and
what I mean a rigorous way I mean like
like I didn't know anything about sales
or marketing or finance or like any of
these subjects and they all seem very
like remote and mysterious and so to
combat this I would just go on Amazon
and type in like sales and then like
find like the top three rated or most
popular sales books and just like read
them and repeat that if you found that
valuable and its really pursue release
'fl like the reading is like one of
probably the most important reading
about business is probably most
important thing that's prepared me for
running for running Dropbox and then
what what was and you talk a little bit
about it in the commencement speech but
I find this transition is kind of the
most interesting one is you know what
you were working on this for two years I
think in through your graduation what
kind of you know it's hard is that you
know you're told to persevere and keep
working on something don't give up but
at some point maybe you are kind of put
a good time after but yeah so I it was
super interesting the beginning because
like you know and when you first get to
work you you you you know you get down
to such important orders of business of
like all right you know I got a
Photoshop a logo and print out business
cards as a founder on them another very
important thing and then hand them out
to people so that so they so that they
know that I'm a founder now you know
it's like this is like the stuff you
know I still do that yes but then you
know what you realize is after that kind
of you know after you're like
incorporated and you get your like fax
back from the Delaware Secretary of
State and these things all seem very
official and important you're like after
your like day number 74 of like I got to
take out the trash like you know we got
to erase the whiteboard and like all is
a it's like you're like actually this is
a lot of work and which was it was good
but so I think with my first company the
I didn't none of neither of us knew what
we were doing at all and so we're
bootstrapping it there's just a lot of
kind of manual labor around like I was
you know we were too cheap to get like
employees so
have any any money so you know who's
going to write the math questions is
like me and that I just still remember
having to like force myself to like
write these math questions and draw
these diagrams and be like alright so
where did the train leave from last time
okay so the train this train leaves you
know Sacramento at data and like and so
I'm like God at some point I'm just like
I can't yes we have people who do that
so it's actually quite fun yeah I
seriously I find that I didn't and so
but but to you know super feel your pain
no is it no in but but the problem
wasn't really the work it was just more
like we were putting a lot of effort
into it and not seeing a lot of return
so it was for me it was it wasn't you
know I it's kind of lost some of the
variety of the work and and so I just
got kind of it just became harder and
harder I felt like I had to push myself
like so much like it and you know I'm
like this is it just became something I
dreaded it became something right up
like tricked myself into like making
progress and I'm like and then I'd start
like it's just like negative spiral
right because you're like you start
resenting the work you start getting mad
at yourself cuz you're like why am I not
more disciplined
likewise like why and it's just like
then which makes you resent it even more
and thinks there's something wrong with
your site it's like all stuff all this
like stuff in your head and and then
what happened was I had a friend of mine
who started a company and did things a
little bit more properly like he had a
co-founder who was like really good
friends with they raised money you know
they could just set up the company like
a good normal company and then they were
just having a blast they were working
would just every waking hour but like
they was having fun like every minute is
what it looked like and felt like and so
I was like at first I'm like oh man
maybe I'm really defective like look
these guys are having no problem with
this but then what happened was I
actually started I would find these
little side projects and I start working
on a pokerbot again reverse engineering
like three people said this is
impossible
alumni get as possible and so I was
really good at the security encounter
reverse engineering part of it and could
do enough of the AI but you know and
there's like this
I was just possessed like I would be
like dragging my computer's around
everywhere like my parents would ask
like what had me come up to New
Hampshire because we like a little place
like this place on a lake where you're
like supposed to get away from
technology you next thing I'm like
putting like three monitors on like the
kitchen stove because there's not enough
room and like working on this thing and
so it but it turned out I mean you never
know how these things are gonna sort of
all line up but then when I was working
on I was still working on the SAT prep
company and my friend Adam who I
mentioned moved out to San Francisco
next thing I know he's he's two years
younger than me but the next phone call
I get from he's like hey I've raised
five million dollars and like I I was
like that's a lot of money like that
number has like two commas in it like
what the hell and this is like my you
know my little brother in our fraternity
I'm like oh my god and so but it just
turned out that you know in part it was
sort of the setup was there like I
really loved algorithms and distributed
systems and I studied computer science
and like these are my favorite things
and so was sort of sort of fertile
ground and then you know one time I lost
I left my thumb drive at home and so I
couldn't get any work done for my
company and the sort of non PR like the
Director's Cut version of sort of the
Dropbox origin story you know so I was
riding taking a ride on the Chinatown
bus the Fung Wah from from Boston to New
York and I left my thumb drive vine and
I'm just like I hate I'm like you know
what are you doing these situations
you're like you know like oh I hate my
thumb drive I'm like I hate myself
so like stupid I'm sorry I'm so
disorganized I keep doing this why can't
I be better and you know just the self
flagellation and that's like there's
nothing else to do for like four and a
half hours but but I had this three
gigabyte Linux virtual machine image
that I need to keep in sync across all
these computers because I worked on with
laptop sometimes sometimes a desktop
sometimes another computer and like
nothing there are a million things that
claim to solve this problem and none of
them actually did and so it was really
personal frustration that led me to open
up the editor and start right
some code that eventually turned into a
Dropbox although I had no idea that
would be the case at the time you know I
mean I think this is an important moment
because you know a lot of times when you
read about Dropbox you said oh yeah he
had the idea of having you know sharing
files across multiple devices and all
that but you know whenever I realize
like no that did what what's amazing
isn't the idea is actually very old idea
in fact you know almost anyone who's
worked on data storage or anything has
for the last 40 years has been trying to
do this and so to me the power of almost
the audacity of what is like this was
like a big problem that a lot of really
smart people had kind of tried to do as
you mentioned maybe even launch
companies on it didn't have really
complete solutions what what was kind of
going on in your head that convinced you
that not like I think the past that I'm
about to take on this problem is going
to be the one that works well it was
just so clear from trying all the other
things that like all they're like a
hundred things that claim to solve this
on paper but in like in practice they
never really worked and they're you know
at school at MIT they have that you
sometimes you like a campus network or a
sort of hard core UNIX II kind of way of
solving this problem but like for a
Windows computer or like a Mac Book like
there's you you know you're stuck
carrying around a thumb drive and
emailing yourself stuff and and that was
your point I was more just amplify the
frustration I'm like guys this is not a
new idea we've thought about this is
like the 60s all right like why the hell
am i forced to do it like really made me
upset and then I you know there's some
conviction I would like a look you know
that the problem with like the all the
on line drives is like these very
specific technical things where it's
like you know it's all a big hack where
the way the on line drive the eye drives
and X drives and for every letter
there's men a drive for all of them they
all worked on the same basic principle
which is like okay we're going to make
we're going to trick your applications
and operating system into thinking that
instead of like when you're when a
program write something to the disk
instead of writing it to the disk on
that inside the laptop
it actually intercepts it sends it over
to the Internet to server somewhere and
gets it back so at first glance like
this is a great idea we'll work with
everything it's you know it's not that
hard but the problem is you're set like
if the server is 100 milliseconds away
instead of five milliseconds away like
your hard drive or less then you get all
these inexplicable problems because like
all ever like millions millions millions
lines of code we're all written with
assumption that this thing is like five
ten milliseconds away and I'm going I'm
going into detail on this example it's
like this there's like no way you can
ever make that work
like you know it's just like laws of
physics and so you need a completely
different approach and sort of a hybrid
we're like okay what you know you have
big and cheap and fast storage locally
and on a server that's but it's like two
swimming pools connected by a straw
right and so use the straw first use the
straw well and to like make it so that
you know you're not waiting for the
swimming pool to make it back and forth
like use it efficiently do that in the
background sinking right so and then it
it just turned out no one had gotten the
technical part right but then there's
also like a user there's like a design
piece of like you know how do you design
the interface how do you make this
what's a metaphor that people can
understand and then there's kind of it
there's like an academic piece of which
like the algorithms and you know how do
you move the files around and things
like that and store them but then
there's like a lot of grungy kind of
operating systems work where you know
how do you make it so that you work in
the oh the fat32 file system every other
file system one it stores you know next
to the name of the file it stores like
when the file was modified and it's a
timestamp and it's a resolution of one
second it's actually more detailed map
alyssum and then any bikes just randomly
on some random operating sub sum random
hard drive you can have a fat32 file
system that stores that modification
time with a resolution to two seconds
and it's like none of the other ones do
that but that one does and so there's
all this weird complexity to the code or
like you know windows xp service pack 3
there be bugs where like the swedish
version of that not the norwegian
version the swedish version of this
light and would just like cause dropbox
to crash and so you know part is those
two things like one is you know a
fundamentally different approach from
what some of the other guys are doing
and then two is the lot of just like
that kind of obsession like the same
thing the same way I was like obsessed
with like making a very well-crafted
like you know SAT question about
quadrilaterals and making the diagram
look like the actual list it was like
then obsessing over making it really
fast reliable and fixing that obscure
bug with Swedish windows and and what
did you realize you start on this you
see a problem you start tackling it and
it is an audacious problem to tackle
when did you say this is real this is
like I have a solution here like this is
already better than what's out there in
industry so first was when I just made
something that worked for myself and I'm
like I could actually I could actually
use it like I would put save something
and it would like show up on my other
computer and I'd be like finally and
then but but it really started to take
shape once I made a video a demo video
of Dropbox like three minute little it's
it's still online somewhere or you can
find it and and I put it on Hacker News
there's this new site for startups and
it just got a ton of it was like top a
hacker news for like two days like if
these were the old days so it was easier
to do that but but that gave me like a
ton of I mean I already decided to quit
my job because I was is complicated so I
just graduated I was working as an
engineer at a start-up and I was
moonlighting on my SAT brother thing
that was the other thing so I you're
asking why like why did I kind of get
frustrated it's like we
my co-founder wasn't going to quit his
job I wasn't really either this thing
was never really going to succeed but it
wasn't it also wasn't going to die
so like it just got kind of frustrating
but anyway so Dropbox really the first
real turning point was when I put the
video up and then Arash my co-founder
saw it on accra news like we got that
later like a week later we got
introduced through mutual friend I'm
sorry from it Paul Graham I was over
rosh my co-founder and then our first
investor paul graham saw the video and
emailed me saying because we just i just
applied solo to Y Combinator with the
idea and so so that's one is your second
interaction with Paul Graham I had a
complicated series of interactions
before so Paul so Y Combinator is kind
of like a plan
College right lots of people want to get
in not enough spots you have this very
competitive dynamic and so actually the
sort of admission system was how I
thought about getting to Y Combinator
and so I had actually been flown out to
California to hang out with some other Y
Combinator founders I also wanted to
pitch Paul on Dropbox and so I showed up
at Y Combinator a little early before
one of the dinners and walked into in
his office and asked if if I could show
him Dropbox and he was very angry about
that he did not visitors were not
welcome so II but the problem with that
it's like imagine you know we all
remember applying to school
imagine having like five minutes with
like the Dean of Admissions and the one
thing that they learn is that like
you're an hey um know if I'm
supposed to pay let's just keep it real
sorry it's all the 12 year olds watching
that's don't say that yes but um but but
that first video was like huge in terms
of getting started yeah and then you get
started and I mean and I mean and this
what year was this was 2007 2007 2007
and then it's just been kind of oh I
mean I actually I don't think I've ever
seen it you guys have got to be one of
the fastest growing organizations maybe
in the history of the valley
oh so it's been growing quickly yeah
they're all like people are sending all
kinds of records these days but but the
company in terms of headcount has grown
really fast and then the user base has
grown from a 2009 we're like a million
users an hour over 300 and and we give
into it you know we're like what are
your you know kind of in hindsight or
now that you can look over the last 7
years I mean what would have been and I
almost view this if we were talking a
little bit about this when before we did
this is you know what's kind of your
your your what would you've told
yourself when you it was an 80 person
organization or 90 percent organization
that you know kind of like either ease
your stress or let you know that
something's coming or ways to manage it
as you grow well I think there's a lot
you know and it's hard to kind of boil
it down to like pithy like phrases of
like oh this is how you know you build a
company it's like you know how do you
play basketball like I want to take a
while to explain
right so but but I think the I don't
really know how to play time not very
good about that also I ok I'm not good
horrible do we look like it alright so
what I would say is some of the earliest
most helpful advice that we got was
really to focus on the people we brought
into the company like make sure
everybody's like really really talented
like so that's probably the best like
hack you can do to make everything else
easier right because you know put a good
person between you and all your problems
right and and our angel investors and
some of our early folks were like I'm
just kept drilling that into our heads
like make sure the talent bar is really
high be very choosy and and I think just
sort of an attitude of of really trying
to systematically train to like
understand like okay well you know
here's what I'm dealing with today but
I'm going to talk to people who are
maybe 6 months ahead a year ahead five
years ahead and like what are they doing
well like what would they I asked as
quite as I hope those talk another CEO
could a thousand person company I'm like
all right you know we're approaching a
thousand people at Dropbox you know what
what am I going to what am I going to
see between a thousand two thousand what
should i watch out for like what would
you put in place now so that as you've
done all these things and grown the
company you know what do you wish you
could do today
so a lot of what I do is sort of think
it is think about that and sort of all
you have to be able to see around
corners and one way to do that is
reading one way to do that is having
mentors and getting advice but and then
the other thing that gives you some calm
is that you know what you read on
TechCrunch or in the press generally you
know when someone tells a story of a
company they're like oh yeah Dropbox it
started out with not a lot of users then
later they had a lot of users and they
did great you know and they just have
this sort of this like this narrative
arc that they you just they're like
you're like well the real truth is like
is that this complicated stuff happened
and this was actually really hard
they're like yeah I know okay two kids
two MIT kids in a dorm room have an idea
they just you know and and so the truth
is like it's actually very complicated
and hard but that all kind of gets
glossed over but when you read like
profiles there's a lot of books that
have been written
about there lately that the everything
store is a book about Amazon's great
book Steve Jobs biography Google Apple
Microsoft Facebook all these Intel like
Oracle like I've read as much as many
kind of profiles on tech companies and
other companies as I could get my hands
on over you know these companies over
the last few decades and you know what
you learn is that you know there's
enough
there's nothing once you sort of look
behind the curtain there's nothing
that's that magical and so and that's
important for people to understand
because you might think like oh I don't
know anything about business so I should
just go like no I'm never gonna be good
at it because I've never been good at it
and that's just something I should go
get like a business guy or where a
person like to to do that stuff because
I'll never be good at it but it's
actually something you can learn and so
I think that mindset of like you know on
a in a week you can probably limit it in
terms of what you can do but like you
know think about playing an instrument
or becoming a doctor or like any things
it's like all of us can realize like
yeah it's a lot of work but I can sort
of see a path from A to B turns out like
most things you want to learn have that
kind of potential like you can you
whether it's public speaking or building
a company or or any of those things like
if you over if you have the attitude
that like you know that and you give
yourself time like you can actually pick
these things up there's nothing that
magical about them so and that's one
thing from these profiles and then the
other thing because you see in the early
days they make all these like really
crazy stupid mistakes and like do all
these things they're like really really
wrong and then that's also therapeutic
is like you realize all these companies
were like a total mess and actually I
see Albert and the coroner Albert is an
early drop boxer Albert can tell you how
what a mess really Dropbox was and say
so what you what you read about is
actually not reflective of reality it's
much Messier and kind of less current
less glamorous process yeah
and I'm about to open it go into some
questions that from from the team but
but just took my last question is you
know where do you see a kind of Dropbox
in 5 10 50 years you know at the end of
your life what do you hope Dropbox has
has done 50 years what were the I don't
know if anybody's made it's like
self-driving boats yet but
that would be an innovation that's I
mean but but in the in it you know you
can't really look that far out but what
we've realized and what we we talk a lot
about is we have this opportunity where
now we have a lot of resources a lot of
really talented people we can solve
these really big problems and then what
we're really working on is building this
home for everybody's most important
stuff right because you think about your
house 20 years ago like you'd walk into
your house to be like you know mail on
the table you'd go in your living room
oh your photos are on your you know in
your kitchen your photos are on your
refrigerator right and you go down the
hall and your briefcase has like your
documents in like all that stuff is now
on servers or in your Dropbox and so we
need this like new kind of home so we we
think all the time about like you know
how can we save hundreds and millions of
people from like these things are really
painful and annoying about technology
like all these little paper cuts like
forgetting your thought like the
equivalent of like these little thumb
drive problems are like everywhere right
and so how do we how do we find the
biggest ones and solve them at massive
scale and so and then specifically you
know we started out with this app that
you put on your computer or your phone
that gives you just like Dropbox folder
but really what you want is you know
what you're using that folder for is
often you're putting photos in there you
know you're getting work done you're
collaborating with other people and so
we're starting to dig into some of those
use cases a little more with things like
we just launched a photo app called
carousel which is like if the gallery on
your phone had like every picture you've
ever taken and if you could text like a
hundred or a thousand photos and videos
at a time
that's what carousel lets you do yet for
some reason that had not really existed
or known like everybody has this problem
just no one solved it yeah awesome so
I'll go into some of these questions the
first one this is this is from Marsha
you can reach your hand wash if you
where's Marsha I don't know where is
Marsha well oh she's remotely so what's
your typical workday like probably the
biggest thing I spent time on is
recruiting and so there's you know often
there will be some kind of fire drill at
night where it's like okay we're
acquiring a company or there's some
candidate and we're fighting with you
know Google or some startup to try to
get them you know there's a tug of war
so it's like and like I'm often you know
myself down here like going on going
big-game hunting for people to join
Dropbox you know so I'll be like in the
Google campus or if you see me if you
see me well these companies you know
what I'm doing
and so recruiting is the biggest thing
and then a lot of that probably the next
biggest thing is just meetings with
small meetings and small numbers with
people on my team around certain
projects so every six months we pick
like you know a dozen things that we
really want to get that are really
important that we want to get done and
then I'll you know I'll be spending time
with them be like okay here's this
here's new stuff we're going to do in
collaboration or here's you know what
answering questions like that what is
Dropbox like what should it be in five
years what will it be in 50 years like
how what kind of place do we want to
create and so and so it kind of and then
there's this very this is much longer
tale of all kinds of other stuff with
it's like partners or customers or you
know just other things yeah it's a hard
question to answer succinctly yeah
that's pretty good this if I'm to show
up at the cottage I had I made something
that um downloads my Google Calendar and
dude if I wrote Python script that down
was my Google Calendar into an Excel
spreadsheet and like triage is my time
on websites it's you have to supervise
you have to like you have to triage the
stuff or you know have someone help you
treat other stuff but but then I had
these like rolling charts of like how I
spent the last week or the last four
weeks the last twelve weeks so that can
cause a lot of people say like oh I'll
use that all right that's interesting
you know data analytics on your time it
is that's it's it's super so I I did
that more a like one of most important
things you need to think of it like as
your job gets more complicated there's
just more stuff competing for your time
it's really important to understand
where it goes you know that's there's a
book called the effective executive by
Peter Drucker it's like that's like any
book on management will like focus on
that so you know but if there's nothing
it's like no one's created a tool where
you can see where your time goes and
it's like everybody you know a lot of
people have that problem so but anyway
so yeah I have been at times very like
about that very cool and so I have a
question from Dylan dealership Dylan's
right over there
so where are some almost interested
unexpected fun technical challenges that
you and your team have faced in the
process of scaling Dropbox to hundreds
of millions of users so I think it's
just fundamentally the challenge of
Dropbox itself and we're building you
know we're trying to build like the file
system for the internet and so how do
you connect you know a billion devices
right and so that comes along with all
kinds of technical challenges where you
know people are saving a billion files
every day on Dropbox and so you know
that's more than there are tweets on
Twitter and this is not like little 140
cases like your like wedding photos
right yeah it Canet nothing you can't
have a bad day alright so so so even
just the core service but then you know
as you branch out then there's all these
interesting things with you know how do
we make a there's more sort of far
afield things like computer vision like
how do we in for photos or something you
might how do we organize your photos for
you search you know pretty much every
kind of like client software we have big
data we have data science we have you
know a bunch of infrastructure stuff
every permutate every possible platform
every if people are like really into
like hard core algorithms we need like
that if we hard people are like really
deep into systems we like unlimited need
for that bunch of storage stuff I mean
it's just it's really all over the map
like it feels like any permutation of
technical challenge we have it at least
in software yeah yeah absolutely and I
think we have timing for one one one
more so this from Joel virtual inertial
right there so he'd like to hear about
hack week and this is where we've had a
little bit of we want to do more of this
how did it get started and has has any
what new stuff has come out of it has
anything actually been productized and
so hack week is basically something we
do every year wherever you guys probably
heard of a hackathon or like a one day
hacking event but we're like alright
let's take this to 11 we'll do a whole
week
because sometimes you know Dropbox it
would've been hard to prove that in a
day but actually the first prototype had
something reasonably working in a week
and and so it's something we do really
to sort of get back to the spirit of
like where we started where you know
there are no constraints a lot of people
were telling us that what we were doing
was a lot of investors told me that
Dropbox is it's a stupid thing to get
into have a yet another storage company
or all the other ones have failed but
like it just doesn't mat like instead of
like talking or debating like actually
write code and just like and if you do
it right like you can change how people
think and so a ton of things have made
it into the product from having to
account having a personal and business
account in Dropbox that was a huge
project that started out as a hack week
project one of my AK week projects was
the new and the way you do notifications
or like those sort of the menu bar and
Dropbox is not like the native and like
with you can see like what's changed and
and have a different UI around that
things like a bunch of security stuff so
two-factor authentication was was
something that that started there a lot
of how you can like rewind your files or
undo things that it was at a quick
project and then a lot of other stuff
which maybe didn't make it one-to-one
like you're like make it pound for pound
into the product but even just like the
when we watch people build like all
these apps on top of Dropbox like that
informed like someone may like I'm you
know a juke box kind of music player
that's a separate app and it just sort
of like plants a seed that may may
manifest itself years later in something
like oh well now instead of just having
the Dropbox app you have all family of
apps like carousel mailbox Dropbox so
that it's it's really just a time for a
just to work on anything except where
you're supposed to be working on be like
a Nunley unleash people and remember
kind of like lift the constraints as day
to day and three it's it's to change how
people think about you know if you have
an idea like prove it and begin you know
you learn as people have like a lot of
really this is a pretty amazing group of
people we have in the company and then
interns like take Dropbox and put put it
in a weather balloon and put an Android
phone
into space where that this phone will be
taking pictures of the ride up and down
and so it's just crazy you just have
this like pictures uploading the drop
box of like space well I just want to
thank you I think right you know I think
I speak for everyone here that you know
it's been a real treat to kind of get to
know you just now so thank you very much
thank you